well if it isn't the scariest thing to
happen to Kim Kardashian since Mary and
Kanye West American Horror Story has
arrived with a brand new season after
the train wreck that was New York if
you've been subbed to my channel for
some time you'll know I've done Recaps
of this show in the past but this season
we're gonna do things a bit different
I'm gonna be covering all the biggest
mysteries Clues and theories rather than
a step-by-step what happened in the
episode no filler just all the good
stuff I'll also leave timestamps below
so you can see all the topics I'll be
covering so spread your legs and strap
yourself in let's see what this season
has to offer at the beginning of the
episode Anna our series protagonist has
her home invaded by a black hooded
figure judging by this figure it appears
to be a woman and one who has an
interest in Anna not going through with
her pregnancy it seems this is the
person who ripped up the sticky note
reminder on her fridge the picture of
her embryo and leaves an ominous message
of don't do it Anna on her mirror she
may also be the one responsible for
changing the times of Anna's
appointments on her phone it feels as
though the writers want us to believe
that this is Ivy the mysterious woman
stalking Anna played by Cara Delevingne
now it could be her but I also want to
pose the possibility of it being Sonia
the artist Dex works with who looks
suspiciously like his ex-wife Adeline in
fact it's the same actress who plays
both roles throughout the episode we
learn a little more about Anna's husband
Dex he was previously married to a
famous vegan Chef by the name of Adeline
who died in a mysterious kitchen fire 10
years ago in the news reports about her
we learned she ran a restaurant called
Hestia named after the Greek god of the
Hearth and Home Anna astex if he ever
tried having children with her to which
he responds it wasn't in the cards
Hestia also happened to be a quote
Eternal virgin according to the news
reports adeline's death was deemed
accidental if Adeline is somehow this
new woman Sonia then it may give her
motivation to stop Anna from having
dex's child in the bathroom at the
restaurant Anna sees these spiky heels
the same ones worn by Sonia at the art
show if Sonia were at the same
restaurant as Dex the man who's
displaying her art surely Anna would
have met her but this is not the case
suggesting Sonia may be stalking her or
decks more strangest Talia saying of
Adeline at this restaurant I can
feed her spirit with us right now
there's also someone in high heels who
follows her in the alley we never see
this person but can hear the sound of
the heels that definitely aren't Anna's
this could be Sonia or Ivy and means
we're dealing with multiple stalkers
Sonia Ivy and Miss preacher who all get
into in a bit we don't know much about
Ivy Anna's the only one who has seen her
which could suggest she may be in Anna's
mind the first time we see her she's
outside Anna's apartment overlooking a
dead bird Anna sees her with the
paparazzi before quickly disappearing
and again in her own home in the
reflection of a knife so the two big
questions I currently have about ivra if
she's real and B if she's good or bad
they're definitely setting her up as
this stalker type figure but this could
be a misdirect of all the characters
we've been introduced to thus far the
one that has my red flags going up is
Dex he starts working with a woman who
looks exactly like his dead ex-wife and
even has the balls to tell and as she
looks not thing like her there's also
the weird interaction between Dex and Dr
Hill it's almost as if Anna isn't even a
part of the process like Dex is calling
all the shots Anna even picks up on this
saying why are you saying that just to
you it makes me think that Dex could be
using eggs from Adeline and having Anna
unknowingly be the surrogate or if Sonia
is a twin sister of Adeline using her
eggs to create a type of child that
would be at least genetically close to
Adeline Dex did call Adeline the love of
his life so just to what extent would he
go to make her memory Live on another
Shady character we're introduced to is
Miss preacher she seems to follow Anna
around and even takes pictures of her
which end up being posted by a user
named annihilate Anna on a Reddit page
called you preacher speaks this would
suggest that Miss preacher is the user
annihilate Anna who has been posting
negative comments about her all over the
Internet unlike Ivy Miss preacher seems
to be a real person as when she arrives
at the fertility clinic stalking Anna
the staff know her by name the attendant
says you know you're not allowed to be
here suggesting this preacher has been
here several times before she may even
know what this Fertility clinic is
really up to this preacher says to Anna
you are her but just who exactly is she
referring to due to the limited
information we have about Miss preacher
and Anna's past it's tough to say but my
guess is that Miss preacher is actually
a good guy who wants to prevent bad
things from happening to her while
meeting with her PR manager Siobhan
Corbin Anna is asked to sign a
discontinued doll from her time on a
show called Summer day this particular
fan also has the odd request of Anna
signing the actual body now this doll
somehow gets out of its packaging and
into Anna's purse we'll also see another
doll left at Andy Cohen's show but this
time with a big X on its stomach when
the one she previously signed had her
initials is Anna doing this and just not
realizing it she is after all on a
cocktail of different drugs and vitamins
that is if what she's being given are
vitamins at all or perhaps something
else to mess with her mind now I wanted
to bring this to your attention and I
could be crazy but in this particular
shot it looks like one of the doll's
eyes is blue and the other Brown this is
the only shot like this in the episode
is it just the way the lighting hits or
was this on purpose and as PR lady also
gives me bad vibes the very fact she met
Anna at an IVF support group could mean
she has ulterior motives to have a child
she even tells Anna straight up that
she'd raise Anna's child if something
were to happen to her and as calendar
time suddenly changing could mean two
things one that Anna is actually crazy
and changes or forgets them herself or
two that someone else has access to her
calendar the only other person who might
have her password is Dex but her
calendar changes while he's sleeping
right beside her unless he gave Anna's
password to someone else the password
after all is Dex 2020 but as far as we
know Dex wants Anna to be on time to
their fertility meetings which would
mean the person hacking her phone is
someone who does not want Anna to go
through with it this could be a case of
hacking since even after Anna changes
her password the hacker is still able to
add appointments as seen in the last
scene when Anna searches Adeline Harding
on her phone I found it very odd that
one of the links has already been
clicked seen here by the link text being
purple did she actually search this
before or is this just an oversight of
the show this episode has a lot of
spider imagery not to mention a literal
spider Anna finds in her hair while at
the park in one creepy scene she pulls
out an extremely long hair or perhaps
it's a strand of webbing the intro
credits also have a lot of spider
imagery and the car Anna takes to dex's
show has a spider hood ornament but even
the word spider is used all throughout
the episode I will help you raise this
little spider baby as if it crawled out
of my own will my baby's gonna come out
a spider one thing I noticed throughout
the episode was the importance of blue
and red in both costuming and set design
blue seems to suggest innocence and
fragility the first time we see Anna
she's in a blue nightgown blue is the
color of the Dead bird's egg an egg
which is broken and considering Anna
says this in the next scene do you still
love me even though I'm broken I don't
think it's a coincidence blue is also
the color of her hospital gown in
contrast we have red symbolizing danger
Ivy wears red the intro credits are
almost all in red the red lipstick the
red TAPS at the restaurant Sonia's red
painting of a mother and child in her
own menstrual blood and the red light
before Anna goes on Andy Cohen's show
the season begins with a pretty ominous
Bible quote unto the woman he said I
will multiply thy pain and thy
conception in pain Thou shalt bring
forth children this is interesting
because the name of the episode is
multiply thy pain the quote itself
refers to the act of childbirth being
painful although in some translations
the word pain is substituted with sorrow
either way it's pretty Grim but if you
read further in Genesis 3 16 you'll get
the next line which is and is desire
shall be to thy husband and he shall
rule over Thee I have a sneaking
suspicion Dex may be the one secretly
pulling the strings over this whole
conception he is ruling over thee now
those are the main topics I wanted to
cover this episode but what did you
think I want to hear your thoughts and
theories in the comments below thanks
for watching please be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
then tell the Daniels to suck my
foreign